I think overall the level of fashion
cooking and and just looks like how
people look I mean I watch I love old
movies and [ __ ] and I look at some guys
and I'm like that guy's [ __ ] 31 he
looks like he's 56. like that's what a
56 year old looks like that lives in a
city you know like some of the people
back then I mean Isaac Brian Denny he
used to exist yeah you know what I mean
like Brian Denny was kind of a sex
symbol to certain types of women my
nanny my grandmother from Ireland loved
Brian Denny now like guys like George
Kennedy George Kennedy always looked
like he was 63. his whole career I don't
know if you know who that guy is but he
was in those uh uh uh look up George
Kennedy he was in Cool Hand Luke yeah he
he actually was played opposite Frank
drebin in the Naked Gun I know exactly
who it is look at that guy's face always
looked old yeah well let's try to get
when he's sort of young look look up
young George Kennedy and still and you
can see too the guy that guy is like you
would not want to fight that guy no on
any level still could pass for his
mid-40s there yeah good looking
distinguished yeah get mad at them eggs
use a distinguished guy yeah there
wasn't there was there was no Timothy
God bless him people smoked and they
drank they ate [ __ ] like they didn't
know how to put put the diet together or
whatever they that they were eating
um you know nowadays I mean
I just met a guy who was an agent and
all he drinks is like these [ __ ]
smoothie shakes and this guy dude I've
never said this about another man he was
radiant yeah like I thought I thought
about him for like three days his hair
was like like a [ __ ] like a yeah you
know like those Collies yeah Westminster
that's a border yeah you would brush he
had like you know when the chicks do
that thing in the shampoo commercial
from behind and it comes down and
there's like that rainbow like that was
guyless guy's hair you think a guy like
that that's so radiant eventually just
hits a point one day where he just is it
like Michael Douglas and falling down
where he just at a stoplight one day
just gets out of his car and just starts
going nuts like that would be him going
out he goes into a Jack In The Box yeah
I guess yeah well that's what I mean
French fries
I mean he loses it and has a mozzarella
stick but I mean I love how you compare
just drinking smoothies yeah to a guy
going on a shooting spree
I just mean that like it seems like it's
got an expiration date that's all like
uh smoothies
oh no I think it was beyond that like I
think he was one of those people that
went to scientists and had his DNA it
was [ __ ] impressive yeah
um so is that important but that or is a
little bit of it like
I don't know I know I understand that it
is impressive to keep yourself look
there's obviously a level of ridiculous
vanity to it but you just know that
that's possible yeah you know it was
very like Michael Jordan right like a
lot of those moves that kids did for the
last 20 years because Jordan showed you
that you could do it right uh and that's
the genius of the first guy the Jimi
Hendrix the Eddie Van Halen's you know
the guys like that so like as far as
like being like in shape
you know yes he that guy did not make me
afraid of of being 60 at some point easy
well yeah he's inspired well people are
getting older and older and looking
better and better and maybe you know I
mean people are
people are thriving
well into old age yeah it's weird it's
it's interesting well considering they
turned our food into poison I don't know
how we're doing it well because we're
turning it we're turning it back into
non-poison but it just takes money
because you can really eat the best of
the best all right now what do you think
you need to make a year yeah to eat the
way a [ __ ] hobo ate in the 1920s
ah where everything was [ __ ] organic
yeah you'd have to make a lot you have
to make a lot what do you think what do
you think the number is
two hundred thousand a year after taxes
in this state easily
to eat wild salmon to eat organic
everything yeah
you don't think you want a great I seem
low food is [ __ ] it might be it's
super expensive and then it goes bad
really quick immediately like the fruits
and vegetables yeah yeah like the way
you eat the fries and the McDonald's on
the way home you gotta be eating the
fruits will you let your children have
fast food every now and then like
because my parents let us have it all
the time which was the wrong way to do
it in the 90s they would just I mean
McDonald it was like Hey Party Time
Wendy's all that stuff very bad Wendy's
then Wendy's was like going out getting
steak when I was like this was amazing
do you remember when they used to have
the newspaper the newspaper tabletop the
old-timey newspapers and a salad bar
yeah that nobody went to nobody went to
it but it had pudding Wendy's was uh the
top of the line fast food when I was
growing up it was the only one that
actually looked like it used real meat
yeah and they had the square Burger
which was weird it was weird but it was
the way for them to say this is meat it
was a way for them to say it's different
we're different yeah it was a weird
brand where they were like no this is an
actual thing yeah to answer your
question I don't take them out for fast
food